- How does this thing work?
Oh, there it goes.
- Hell no!
- It’s Bill…
O’BRIEN!
- Ah!
- Deshaun, please don't hang up!
I know you’re mad about the DeAndre trade,
but I can’t control what the GM does.
- You’re the GM.
- Exactly, I can’t control what I do.
Plus, you’ve still got Will Fuller.
- This Will Fuller?
- Hey Fam—
OH NO, I HURT MYSELF ANSWERING THE PHONE.
I'll be back soon.
- See.
Wait...
Coach, what are you doing?
- Hey, yeah,
I’ll trade J.J. Watt for your sourdough starter
and three rolls of toilet paper.
You'll do two? OK.
- I know you’re bored during quarantine,
but stop. making. impulsive decisions.
- You’re a good scrambler,
so we could probably get rid of your
offensive line again.
- OK, I'm back for good now.
Y'all watch Tiger Kin—
OH GOD I TRIPPED OVER THE COUCH.
- I know you’re upset,
but in return for DeAndre
we got a SECOND-ROUND PICK.
Can’t really evaluate the players, though, right now,
so probably just gonna pick the
guy who interviews best on FaceTime.
- Just admit you have beef, coach.
No, we’re cool, see?
Yo! What up, NUK?
- Yo, real quick,
how do you punch someone over the internet?
OK, here,
remove Coach from chat—
I SAVED PENN STATE
AND I’LL SAVE THE TEX—
- Cool plant, bro.
- Oh, no, that’s Kyler Murray.
- Yo, what’s good, Deshaun?
- If you.
- Liked
- This video
- Subscribe below
- For more.
- Or we’re not
- Jason
- And Jason McCourtey.
- No, you’re Devin.
- I’m pretty sure you’re Devin.
- Which of us is Devin?
- Uh, you!
- ME?
- I’ll be Devin.
- Thanks Jason.